So, uh, literally the, the
science of toxicology is the, uh,
is the science of poisons.
Uh,
it is the study of adverse affects on,
uh,
on humans,
but really on life generally.
So when we start thinking about what is,
how is it is and what is toxic,
we,
we have a range of things because
toxicity is really any kind of biological
adverse consequence,
right?
But nobody would suggest that they were
all created equal. So if we look at this,
this scale,
things that we largely consider
less serious as it were,
are the things that are reversible
if something causes you to,
to tear up. But when
it's a, you know what,
I'm in closets you to tear up,
but when you remove the angina goes
away and there's no lasting damage.
So it's reversible. It's not
really debilitated, debilitating,
a tear up for a, for awhile.
Don't see for awhile, but, uh,
not life threatening. So that's down here
with rashes, caused headaches, et Cetera,
et cetera. And then of course,
what we consider more serious,
irreversible debility,
a debilitating life threatening
everything from birth defects,
uh, nervous system, uh, uh,
damage, cancer, etc. Etc.
This is perhaps the most important
slide of today's lecture.
This is the relationship
between these toxic effects.
So we're going to be talking about and,
uh,
the physical chemical properties of the
chemicals that we've been discussing for
the past weeks.
All of these different types of toxicity,
wide range of toxicity,
different toxic pathways that we'll
discuss are directly derived from these
physical chemical properties.
You cannot have these different toxic
effects without the right combination or
depending on your perspective,
the wrong combination of physical chemical
properties in order to make it happen.
We're going to be talking a lot about
how these chemicals get into our bodies
and how they react with
different biological receptors.
All of these different
steps,
all of these key aspects are related to
these and a wide range of other physical
chemical properties.
So if you're wondering what the link is,
this is it.
This is at the foundation.
Why have we been talking about all of
the physical chemical properties for the
past week? All of these different physical
chemical properties because of this.